Last time,
uh,
we were giving examples of what might
happen if one takes seriously that
extraordinary 11th footnote and websites,
the intentional fallacy in which he says
the history of words after a bomb was
composed may well be relevant to the
overall structure of the poem and should
not be avoided owing simply
to a scruple about intention.
That's what essentially that's what
wimps that says in the footnote.
So I went back to the great
creator raising his plastic
arm and suggested that,
well,
maybe after all,
there might be some good way of
complicating the meaning of akin side by
suggesting that the modern anachronistic
meaning of plastic would be relevant to
the sense of the poem.
This is by the way,
and adjust just because one can make
this claim and I think make it stick in
certain cases, it doesn't mean that
the proposition is any less outrageous.
I'm just doing it.
Imagine a philologist being confronted
with the idea that the meaning of words
add a certain historical moment,
uh,
isn't the only thing that matters in
understanding the meaning of a poem. Um,
so I just wanted to give another
example a little closer to home, uh,
of the poem of Yates 1935 poem,
Lapis Lazuli.
I began talking about it.
It's a forum which begins,
I have heard that hysterical women say
they are sick of the Palette and fiddle
bow of poets that are always gay.
Now this is a bar that,
you know,
the storm clouds of the approaching
war are beginning to gather. Uh,
a lot of people are saying, enough
of this kind of a, you know,
if feet culture, uh, we need to
think about, um, important things,
uh, particularly about, uh,
politics and the social order. Uh,
by the way, a very powerful
argument in 1935, but in any case,
Yates was on the other
side of the controversy and
insisted after all that there
is a continuing role for art as indeed
on the other hand, there may well be.
And he said,
so he's,
he's sick of everybody saying they
don't want to talk about painting,
they don't want to talk about music and
they don't want to talk about poets who
are always gay. All right. So then
the poem continues. It involves,
it involves a stone, a piece
of Lapis Lazily, uh, that you,
that that has a kind of a flaw in it,
which is like a watercourse
and where one can imagine, um,
a pilgrim climbing, uh, toward
increased enlightenment.
Uh,
and as the poem goes on,
Yates talks about the way in
which civilizations crumble.
That is to say all things fall apart,
but then it's possible to build
them back up. And he says,
all things fall and are built again.
And those that build them again are gay.
Now,
as I said last time,
needless to say,
Yates was not aware of the anachronistic,
meaning that we may be tempted
to bring to bear on the poem.
Yates is thinking of nature is
thinking of, of, of, of a word further,
which probably is best
translated, joyous, uh,
energetically joyous. Uh, and uh,
he is just borrowing that word from
the translation of a book by nature.
Well and good.
But if you were a queer theorist or
if you were interested in making a,
not a week, but a strong claim for, uh,
the importance of queerness
in our literary tradition,
you would be very tempted to
say this enriches the poem,
not just in other words,
that they are energetically
joyous as creators,
but also that in our contemporary
sense of the word, they're gay. Now,
this again,
as in the case of akin side,
may or may not raise the
hackles of the philologists,
but there's a certain sense in
which from a certain point of view,
it's difficult to deny that it
doesn't land a sir, that, that,
that it doesn't lend a certain coherence.
Additionally complex coherence
to the nature of the poem.
All right, and then, you know, I
mean, we have Tony the tow truck.
You're probably beginning to wish I
would refer to it. So why don't I,
in the second line of tone
of the tow truck, we learn,
I live in a little yellow
garage. Now, of course,
the dean notation as of that of the word
yellow as clearance Brooks would say,
is that the garage is
painted a certain color.
The conotation,
which undoubtedly though
the author had no notion of,
wasn't thinking of this
is a book for toddlers.
The connotation is somehow or another,
there's the imputation of cowardice,
possibly also the derogatory
imputation of being Asian.
Maybe Tony is Asian. Well,
okay, well, you know, this has,
this has nothing to do with the text
we say. And yet at the same time,
suppose it did,
I mean we could interrogate it,
we could interrogate the author
psychoanalytically we could say, hey,
wait a minute. You know, okay,
so you say it was painted yellow,
why don't you say it's
painted some other color?
And we could begin to put a certain amount
of pressure on the text and possibly,
as I say, begin to do things with it, um,
which are a kind of five finger exercise
and we'll be doing a lot more of that
sort of thing, but which
might work. All right.
These are examples of the extraordinary
implications of [inaudible] 11th
footnote. And also I think, um,
perhaps in advance of today's discussion
clarified to some extent the importance
for critics of this kind
of the notion of unity.
In some ways,
everything we have to say today
will concern the idea of unity.
In other words,
a connotation is valuable and ought
to be invoked even if it's fill a
illogically incorrect if it
contributes to the unity,
the complex building up of
the unity of literary texts.
If on the other hand it is what got
them or would call a bad prejudice,
that is to say sip some
aspect of my subjectivity
that nothing could possibly be
done with in thinking
about in interpreting the
text, then you throw it up.
So the criteria is,
is it relevant to the unified form that
we as critics are trying to realize in
the text and that criterion,
as I say,
not just for the sorts of
of semi facetious readings
we can do with [inaudible]
11th footnote,
but also for ratings that may at
least have some marginal plausibility.
This sense of unity is what governs
interpretive decisions of this kind.
All right now a word or two about the
antecedents of the new criticism and the
first place, the 30s and
forties, a in the academic world.
Bare witness to uh,
the rise of a cannon of taste,
largely introduced by the
great modernist writers,
particularly by ts Elliot.
You may notice that Brooks for example,
has a kind of done obsession.
He gets that from Elliot's essay,
the metaphysical poets,
uh,
which is a review essay of a volume
of [inaudible] Donne's poems edited by
somebody named Grierson,
which may done overnight
for a great many readers.
The central poet in the English
tradition. Brooks is still, as I say,
very much under the influence of this.
Well,
Elliot in the metaphysical poets says
some rather interesting things that had
far reaching consequences for
the new criticism. He says,
poetry in our own time,
such is the complexity
of the world we live in.
Poetry must be difficult.
He says poetry has to reconcile
all sorts of disparate experience.
Reading spinosa the smell of cooking,
the sound of the typewriter.
All of this has to be yoked together
in the imagery of a good poem,
particularly of a metaphysical poem.
And this model of complexity is what
matters both for modern literature and for
literary criticism.
Now,
by the same token,
other modernists like Jane's joys are
also contributing to this idea of the
independent unity of the work of art and
Steven Herro portrait of the artist as
a young man.
You remember Steven in his disquisition
on form and Aquinas and all the rest of
it argues that the work of art,
it's something that is cut off from its
creator because its creator withdraws
from it. Uh, and and simply
Paris, his fingernails in the,
in the famous expression. Um, it's
very interesting you remember that,
that in the winds at that you
read last time women's at argues,
I think probably thinking
about that passage and Joyce,
that the work of art is cut
off from its author at birth.
This isn't, this is an umbilical
cord he's talking about.
It has no more connection with its author
from birth on and roams the world on
its own. And so ideas like this, as I say,
are taken from the aesthetic and Pratt
and practical thinking about the nature
of the work of art that one finds
in modernism. In the meantime,
the academic setting
in the 1930s when ransom in particular
is writing his political manifestos,
the new criticism and the world's body
and attacking most of what's going on as
it's being done by his colleagues.
He has two things in particular
in mind in the first place,
old fashion philology the kind of of
thinking about literary texts that would
insist that plastic means what it means
in the 18th century and in the set and a
lot of that was being done.
This is the golden age of the
consolidation of the literary profession.
Additions are being created.
The great learning journals
are in their early phase.
Knowledge is actually still
being accumulated about
the base having to do with
the basic facts of the literary tradition
that we didn't know a great deal about
certain authors until this period of
flourishing of philology in the very late
19th and early 20th
century took hold and it,
and pretty much created
for us the archives that we
now use today in a variety
of ways.
So although the new critics were
fed up with philological criticism,
I don't mean to be condescending toward
it or to suggest that it didn't play a
crucially important role in the
evolution of literary studies. Now,
the other thing that was going
on, and here, I don't know,
depending on one's viewpoint,
perhaps some measure of
condescension might be in order,
but these two were spectacular figures.
The other thing that was going on was
there was a vogue for what might be called
appreciative teaching.
That is, I mean, the,
the contemporary and colleague of Iaa
Richards at Cambridge was the famous
queue, Sir Arthur quiller
couch, who's left, who's,
who's mesmerizing lectures,
um,
had virtually no content at all.
They were simply evocations
appreciative evocations of great works.
Of Literature.
And I have to say that it yell
exactly contemporary with queue.
We had a similar figure.
The person after whom felt skate is
named the Great William Lyon Phelps who
would enter the classroom,
begin rapturously to quote Tennyson would
clasp his hands and say that that was
really good stuff. Uh, and
the students were, and, and,
and the students were so appreciative
that they gave hundreds and thousands of
dollars to the university, uh, ever
after. Um, the, in other words,
this is valuable teaching,
but, but, but again, you know,
but, but again, the new
critics were fed up with it.
This was the atmosphere they found
themselves in and what they wanted.
And this anticipates the
atmosphere that you'll,
you'll see the Russian formalists found
themselves in when we turned them,
turned to them next week,
what they wanted with something like rigor
or a scientific basis or some sort of
set of principles that could actually be
invoked so that the business of credits,
criticism could be,
could become more careful and systematic,
less scattershot, less
effusive, and so on. So this is,
this is in effect the
backdrop, uh, in which, um,
in the American academy but
influenced as we'll now see, uh,
by certain trends in the British Academy,
uh,
arose in the 30s and in the forties.
All right.
Now
the first figure I want to talk a little
bit about in the first figure whom you
read it for. Today's assignment
is I a Richards Richards,
ah,
before he became a,
before he joined the English department
at Cambridge was actually a psychologist
and trained as a Pavlovian
psychologists so that when you read, uh,
in his essay about stimuli and needs,
uh, you see pretty much
where you stand. It is,
I mean his sense of the way in which
the mind reacts to the world to its
experience, the way in which, uh,
it's an uncomplicated reaction
or a resisting reaction or a,
an adjusting reaction all has very
much to do with Pavlovian principles.
Uh,
and these governed to some extent
Richard's his understanding of his boat,
even of his literary vocation.
Um,
during the period when he wrote 1924
when he wrote principles of literary
criticism for Richards reading
is all about experience.
That is to say the way in which the
mind is affected by what it reads.
And so even though, uh, his
subject matter is literature,
he is nevertheless constantly
talking about human psychology.
That is to say what need
is answered by literature,
how the psyche responds to literature,
what's good and bad about
psychic responses and so on.
This is th th th this is
the intellectual focus.
In other words of Richard's his work.
Now another thing,
another aspect of his having been and
continuing to be a scientist is that
Richard's really did believe,
seriously believed in reference.
That is to say in the way in which
language really can hook onto the world.
Verifiable and falsifiable statement is
for Richard's the essence of scientific
practice. And he cares very
much about that, that it's not,
I mean he does not, in other words,
share with so many literary critics,
perhaps even with Brooks who follows him
and making the fundamental distinction
I'm about to describe it.
He does not share with the majority of
literary critics and artists, uh, uh,
kind of distaste for science. I mean, he,
and this by the way is also true of
his student Samson who was a math major
before he became an English major.
Both of them, uh, take very seriously,
uh,
a the notion that there can
be a scientific basis for
what one does in English
or in literary studies.
So another aspect of it for Richards is
because he takes science so seriously,
is that he actually reverses the idea
that we talked about last time in Sydney
and cotton and Coleridge
and wild and whimsy,
that he actually reverses the idea
that it's art that's autonomous.
If you look on page seven,
66 in the left hand column,
you'll find him saying that
science is autonomous to,
and what he means by that is that
scientific facts can be described in
statements without the need for any
kind of psychological context or any
dependency on the varieties of human need.
It is autonomous in the
sense that it is a pure, um,
uncluttered and [inaudible] influenced
declaration of fact or falsehood.
Then he says to declare science autonomous
is very different from subordinating
all our activities to it.
And here's where poetry comes in.
It is merely to assert that so far as
anybody of references is undistorted,
it belongs to science.
It is not in the least to assert that
no references may be distorted if
advantage can thereby gained be gained.
And just as there are innumerable human
activities which require undistorted
references, scientific activities
if they are to be satisfied.
So there are innumerable other human
activities, not less important,
which equally require distorted
references or more plainly fictions.
Here you see Richard's is
basic distinction between
what he calls scientific
statement and what he
calls emotive statement.
The distinction between,
uh,
between that which is truly referential,
that which is in controvert,
controvert ugly,
verifiable or falsifiable on the one hand,
and that which is emotive.
Later on,
Richard's changes his vocabulary and
he no longer talks about scientific and
emotive language.
He talks instead even more dangerously
from the standpoint of anybody who likes
poetry.
He talks instead of statement,
meaning science and pseudo statement,
leading poetry. I mean here,
we're really out on a limb if
you're going to defend poetry,
has Richards kept doing
as pseudo statement,
but of course pseudo statement is just
another expression for what he calls here
fiction.
Now,
why on earth once we sort of settle into
this vocabulary and once we get used to
this clearly a unquestioningly
scientific perspective,
why on earth do you need pseudo
statement or fiction at all?
We know very well by the way,
that they're are scientists to simply
cannot stand to read poetry because it's
fault. Right? You know, it's, I mean
it, it just as Richard says, you know,
poetry, there's a, so there's, there's,
there's always something kind of archaic
or atavistic about poetic thinking.
It's not just that, it's not trying
to tell the truth as Sydney said,
nothing lives because it
never afirma's not just that,
it's not trying to tell the truth.
It is in fact said Richard's go
so far as to say following Plato.
It is in fact lying poetry.
Poetry is constantly getting itself
in trouble and in all sorts of ways.
Um, and the all, I mean on
page seven 68, for example,
I know it seven 68, although I can't
find my reference in the lecture,
see if I can see if I can
find it in the book. Um,
okay,
it
is evident and he says at the top,
sort of toward the top of the
right hand column seven 68,
it is evident that the bulk of poetry
consists of statements which only the very
foolish would think of
attempting to verify.
They are not the kinds of things
which can be verified pack of lies,
pack, you know, I mean,
and then we say, you know,
it usually follows from this that somebody
liked this points out that whereas we
all know that the democratic society
is the best society to live in.
Poetry prefers society. It makes
better poetry and what, whereas we all,
and whereas we all know that the
universe is of a certain kind, uh,
we can't even call it Copernican anymore.
Poetry has this odd preference
for Ptolemaic astronomy and in,
in other words,
everything about poetry is atavistic.
It's a throwback to some
earlier way of thinking.
There's some kind of late
primitivism in poetic thinking. Um,
and Richard scenes cheerfully
to embrace this idea.
That's what he means by fiction or suit.
PSEUDOS taper.
So why on earth do we want it?
We want it according to Richards because
it answers needs in our psychological
makeup that science can't answer.
In other words,
we are, you know, a chaos of desires.
Some of them are involved.
The desire for truth that is to say
for what we can learn from science,
but a great many of our desires have
nothing to do with any notion of truth,
but rather our needs that require
fanciful or imaginative fulfillment,
fulfillment of other kinds.
And the reason this fulfillment
is important and can be
valued is according to
Richards that these needs,
unless they are organized,
harmonized so that they work together in
what he sometimes calls a synthesis can
actually tear us apart.
Literature is what can't reconcile
conflicting or opposing needs.
And Richard's cares so much about
this basic idea that in another text,
not in the text you've just
read, he says, shockingly,
poetry is capable of saving us. In
other words, poetry is capable of doing.
Now what religion used
to do poetry and rubber,
if this is a scientist,
poetry is no more true than religion,
but it can perform the
function of religion and is
therefore capable of saving
us.
And so even despite the seeming derogation
of the very thing that he purports to
be celebrating in books like the
principles of literary criticism,
Richard's does hold out an extraordinarily
important feeling for the mission of
poetry to harmonize conflicting needs.
That's the role of poetry
and that's what it does.
Simply by evoking our wishes,
our desires,
irrespective of truth in there,
complicated,
chaotic form and synthesizing them
organically into something that amounts to
psychological piece,
something that leaves us,
it's a little bit like
Aristotle's idea of Catharsis,
which can be understood
in a variety of ways,
but Milton at the end of Samson agonists,
these understands it in one way.
When he says,
now we have as a result of this tragedy,
calm of mind,
all passion spent.
That could be the motto to Richards,
his work, the experience of art,
the experience of poetry,
the reconciliation of conflicting
needs,
results in a kind of catharsis,
calm of mind, all
passion spent. All right.
Now Richard's had a student,
an undergraduate student,
William Thompson, who had, as I say,
had been a math major who
decided he'd switched to English.
He went to Richardson and he said,
Hey, he had an idea about ambiguity.
He said he thought he thought there was
quite a bit that could be written about
it. Um, and so he wondered if Richard's
would mind if, if maybe he worked on that.
Richard said, fine, fine. Sounds terrific.
Uh, go do it. So a few months later,
Amston brought him the manuscript of one
of the greatest books of criticism in
the 20th century and one of the most
amazingly surprising seven types of
ambiguity.
The brief excerpt you have in your packet.
I trust that you have picked it up by
this time at Tyco, your photocopy packet.
The brief excerpt you have from Samson
is taken from seven types of ambiguity.
Um,
I think [inaudible] is the funniest.
A person who has ever written
literary criticism. Uh,
I think that his dead pan way of bringing
things down to earth when they get a
little too high Falutin, uh, is, you know,
involves the skill of a
genuine stand up comic. Uh,
his timing is perfect. Uh, he
has, in other words, all of the,
all the attributes of a
great comic writer. Uh,
I enjoyed reading him so much that when
I was asked to write a book about him,
I agreed to do so. Um,
I've always been like that.
I enjoyed that Byron was the only
person I enjoyed reading during the nail
biting and tense period
of studying for my orals.
So I wrote my dissertation on
Byron as a result of that. Um,
nothing complicated,
no deep reason for doing these things,
but Amsa and I hope you
enjoy, uh, he's a page Turner.
Uh, and his extraordinary
brilliance as a critic,
a is really just part of the
experience of reading him. Uh,
I'm particularly interested in the,
in the excerpt you have in what
he does with his notion of,
because this is his way of responding to
enthusiastic or appreciative criticism.
One of the tricks of Q
and Billy [inaudible],
Billy Phelps and [inaudible] and all the
other sort of authors and lecturers in
this mode was to say that
they read for atmosphere that,
that that was something that one just
felt along ones bloodstream or in the
pulses.
One,
one encountered great literature and
their purpose as lecturers and as critics
was to evoke the atmosphere of things.
And so absent says, well, you know,
atmosphere, certainly, uh,
certainly that exists and we can talk
about it and all sorts of ways. Um,
but after all,
what is the use of atmosphere?
What does the use of any aspect of
literature? If as good scientist,
we can't analyze it if we can't
somehow or another account for it.
If there is atmosphere in the passage
I'm about to quote from Macbeth,
it must be atmosphere of a certain
kind and there for a certain reason.
And what follows it seems to me is one
of the most staggeringly beautiful,
wonderful, amazing rifts, uh,
on a passage of literature
that you can encounter.
I'm sorry if I sound a little bit
like Billy Phelps, but I do get,
I do get excited. Um, uh, he quotes,
he quotes the passage from Macbeth,
uh, as Amston says, uh, you know,
the murderers have just left the room and,
and uh,
Macbeth is sort of twiddling his thumbs
hoping it's getting dark because it's
got to get dark before Banquo
can be killed. So natural
he looks out the window,
see just to see how the
time is going. Um, and uh,
and this is what he says, come
ceiling nights, scarf up the tender.
I have pitiful day that with thigh bloody
and invisible hand cancel and tear to
pieces that great bond that keeps us
Pale amps and doesn't mention this word
Pale, but in juxtaposition
with the crows and Rooks,
it strikes me that it itself is an
interesting woman in the passage light
thickens and the crow
makes wing to the rookie.
Would Anson Italicize that?
Because while he has something to
say about every part of the passage,
which all good criticism by the way,
should do you quote something.
So he's not thinking about all of it.
Okay. Uh, and, but, but, but, but,
but,
but Anson italicized is these particular
lines because it's going to be the true
focus of what he'll say later.
Good things of day begin to droop and
drowse while nights black agents to their
praise,
do rouse Dow marvel step my words,
but hold these lady Macbeth has
come into the room, you know,
so now marvels at my words,
but hold the still things bad begun,
make strong themselves by ill.
So pretty. Go with me. All right.
So Amston is fascinated by this
passage and then he gets the,
he gives you in the next few paragraphs,
the amazing variety of grounds
for his fascination. Um,
and he says, look, this is,
this is what people mean when
they talk about atmosphere.
It's not just something
you feel on your pulse.
It's something that can be described.
Something that can be analyzed.
And I just want to touch on
the last part of it. He says,
rooks live in a crowd and I
mainly vegetarian absence.
Allison's the person who says that,
uh,
that the ancient mariner shot the
Albatross because the crew was hungry.
He points out that I'm 17,
1998 edition of the rime of the ancient
mariner a biscuit worms had gotten into
the hardtack.
So naturally he says the particular kinds
of Albatross that the Marriner shot,
I am told makes it very tolerable broth.
This is,
this is the mode of William Hansen.
Uh, and so and so he begins here,
Brooks live in a crowd and
are mainly vegetarian, cro,
maybe either another name for rook,
especially when scene alone or it
may mean the solitary carrion crow.
This subdued pun, this
ambiguity. Remember,
this is a book about ambiguity.
This subdued pawn is made to imply here
that Mac Beth looking out of the window
is trying to see himself as a murderer
and can only see himself as in the
position of the crow,
that his day of power now is closing.
That he has to distinguish himself from
the other rooks by a difference of name,
Rook Crow,
like the kingly title.
Only that he is anxious at bottom to be
one with the other rooks not to murder
them,
that he can no longer or that he may yet
be United with the rookery and that he
is murdering Banquo in a for Lauren
attempt to obtain peace of mind.
Well,
I just,
I'm not at all sure there's anything
more to be said about that passage,
which is debt, which, which,
which I think lays to rest.
And it does.
So by insisting on a complex mode
of ambiguity that governs the path,
not atmosphere,
short call it atmosphere if you like,
as long as you're willing to
subject it to verbal analysis,
as long as you're willing to show how
and why the atmosphere is exactly of the
nature that it is,
that it arises and other words.
And here is um, the relationship
between Rick Richards and Anson,
that it arises out of a complex
state of mind that poetry,
the poetry of this speaker,
speaker slash murderer,
that poetry is attempting
desperately to reconcile,
to harmonize just as he is attempting
desperately to be reconciled and
harmonized with the society from
which he has alienated himself.
And of course failing
Macbeth is not Shakespeare.
Shakespeare is poetry.
Attempting to do something which in the
immediate psychological circumstances it
can't do,
but in the process,
evoking an extraordinary complexity of
effort on the part of the mind to be
reconciled through the medium of language.
As I say,
this is the sense in which
amps and follows Richards,
but at the same time there's
something rather different between,
first of all,
Anson Anson doesn't really kind of settle
into a sense that it's all about the
reader that has to say it's,
it's,
it's all about the reader's
experience of the literary.
Richard's is actually an Avatar of
figures like either like a Hans Robert
Galson,
Stanley fish who,
and we'll be discussing later in the
syllabus who are interested in reader
response.
That is to say,
and the way in which we can talk about
the structure of reader experience.
Amazon is sort of interested in
that and just as he's the adjusted,
he's fascinated by the texture of,
of, of, of textual evidence itself.
And he is also very interested,
much more so than Richards and certainly
more so than the new critics from whom
he sharply diverges in advance.
In this respect.
He's also much more interested
in authorial intention.
That is to say for him,
literary criticism is always an
appeal to authorial attention.
Mind you,
he ascribes to authorial attention the
most amazingly outrageous things that
other critics threw up their
hands in despair about.
But nevertheless it is for him always
still an appeal to authorial attention at
bottom.
Anson doesn't really settle into the
rigorous consideration of the author or of
the text or of the reader as,
as it were a separate functions for Anson.
There's a kind of a fluid and easy
movement back and forth between what for
hermeneutics are three very different
phenomena, author, text, reader,
um, for Ramson it's, it's,
it's a kind of synthetic may launch
that appeal that that's ultimately and
appealed to the author.
That certainly involves both the
working on the text itself and also
understanding its effect on,
on the reader. So all of this,
uh, distances, Anson from
Richard's to a certain extent.
But the most important difference I
think between Anson and the other figures
were discussing a difference,
which makes it even a little bit complex
to say that he's a precursor of the new
criticism is that Anson very rarely
concerns himself with the whole of a text.
He isn't really interested in the of the
poem is simply interested in saying as
much as he can about
certain locally facts.
Certainly with the implication
possibly that this has a bearing on our
understanding of let's
say the whole of Macbeth,
but he doesn't set about
doing a systematic reading
of the whole of Macbeth.
He always zooms in on something,
thinks about it for a while,
and then goes away and
thinks about something else.
Leaving us to decide whether it has a
genuine bearing on the entirety or on the
literary wholeness or unity of Macbeth.
Anson is interested in the
complexity of local effects.
And another thing to say
about Emerson's perspective,
which makes him differ sharply,
I think from Richards and
from the later new critics,
is that Anson is perfectly willing to
accommodate the idea that maybe just as in
the case of the psychology of Mac Beth,
the character that may be poetry doesn't
reconcile conflicting needs maybe after
all poetry is x is an expression of
the irreducible conflict of our needs.
The s the last chapter of
seven types of ambiguity.
His seventh ambiguity is actually as
amps and said about some fundamental
division in the writer's mind.
There you see he divergence
from his teacher Richards.
He's fascinated by the way in which
literature doesn't unify opposites or
reconcile needs but leaves
things as it found them,
but exposed in all of their complexity.
Polderman more than once invoked Amston
as a precursor of deconstruction,
not of the new criticism
and for this reason,
for the reason that he's not concerned
with unity and that he's not concerned
with the idea of the
reconciliation of opposites.
Empson I think can rightly be
understood as a freakin precursor of
deconstruction because deconstruction
follows the new criticism of course,
and being a mode of close reading and
there has never been a better close reader
then Anson,
but it needs to be set before turning
away from Anson who's influenced was
widespread despite this divergent.
It needs to be said that his purposes
for close reading are actually very
different from the purposes of
the new criticism. New critics,
the American new critics,
particularly Brooks,
who's preoccupation with unity
is something he freely confesses.
Uh, and something that, uh, well we've
got 10 minutes, so I'm not going to,
I shouldn't,
I shouldn't rush ahead prematurely up
something that you can see to be at the
heart of what Brooks is doing.
Now here he works Brooks in the well
rod earn and modern poetry in the,
and the other books for what she's well
known uses a variety of different words
to describe the way in which the
complexity of literature is placed in the
service of unification.
In the essay you're reading here,
he uses the word irony. He admits that
maybe he stretches the word irony,
but he tries to argue that the variety
of effects that he focuses on in his
essay, uh, have to do with irony.
And another great essay, the first,
the first chapter of the well rod earn,
he talks about paradox.
Obviously these are related ideas and
elsewhere he takes up other ways of
evoking the way in which sort of complex
feelings and thoughts are brought
together. Um, ensigns word ambiguity, uh,
continues to play an important role in
the work of the new criticism. And, uh,
and it is,
uh,
at least it puts itself forward as a
candidate to be an alternative term that
one might use if one got tired
of saying irony or paradox.
There are a variety of words.
In other words and other words
given by the poet critic Allen Tate,
one of the founding figures of
the new criticism is tension.
That is to say the way in which,
uh, the literary text resolves, uh,
oppositions, uh, um, uh,
as a tension that it's a holding
in suspension of conflict,
experienced as tension.
So there are these varieties of ways for
describing what's going on in a text.
It's interesting, I think that if one
thinks of donated the tow truck, um,
one can think of the, at the, uh,
when you go home and study it,
you'll see what I mean. Uh, there's a
complex pattern of imagery as it were,
between pulling and pushing.
There's a tremendous amount of pulling
and pushing that goes on in Tony.
The tow truck will revert to,
especially to the notion of pushing
in other contexts later in the course.
But for the moment you can see,
uh,
the way in which there is a tension
between that which pulls and that which
pushes, which is one of the
motive forces of the story. Uh,
and that I think is an
example also if there is,
if it is ironic that Tony is now stuck
and instead of pulling needs to be
pushed, if it is in some Brooks in
sense, ironic that that is the case.
Uh,
we can understand that as irony
or as tension or ambiguity.
So in any case, uh, that, you know,
there's one way and there's one way in
which Tony is probably not a good proof
text for the new criticism. You
remember that in my credo, the little,
the little sort of excerpt that you get
at the beginning of the book section in
your anthology, Brooke says, um,
poetry should be about moral things,
but it shouldn't point a moral
that and obviously, you know,
uh, tone of the tow
truck points immoral. Um,
and so would be subject to a kind
of devaluation on those grounds.
Uh, but, but the new criticism, even
though there are ways of reading,
Tony, as I've been suggesting
new critically right now,
the ideal of unity for Brooks,
for the new critics in general is that
it be complex that it warp the statements
of science that it bring to bear a
tension between the denotation and the
connotation of words that were yellow in
the second line of Tony, the tow truck,
it's denotation is that
it is a certain color,
the color that Tony's garages painted.
The connotation I have suggested is
of the variety of kinds that one might
gingerly approach.
Uh,
in thinking about complicating
the texture of the story,
uh, in any case, uh,
the tension between Dana rotation and
connotation is part of the way in which
irony works.
So the question again is,
and the question it seems to me raised
in advanced by Amston is why should these
sorts of tension, these,
these movements of,
of complex reconciliation result in unity.
Uh,
it's very interesting. Brooks is reading
if she dwelt among on common ways.
The Wonderful Lucy poem by Wordsworth
emphasizes the irony of the poem
Brookfield's that he's on very
thin ice talking about Wordsworth,
Ian Irony at all, but at
the same time, you know,
does bring it out rather beautifully
talking about the irony of the poem, uh,
basically as the way in which you can't
really say that Lucy can be a flower and
a star simultaneously. She's a flower,
she's perishable, she's half hidden,
uh, she's ultimately dead
and in the ground. Uh,
whereas a star,
uh,
would seem to be something that
she just can't be mapped onto.
If she is this half hidden thing,
but at the same times work says,
well after all she is
a star to the speaker.
He's just saying she's a star to me.
She has a flower half hidden, uh,
unnoticed to everyone else.
And the relationship between the depth
of the speakers feeling and the obscurity
of Lucy in the world is the irony
that the speaker wants to lay hold of.
And that reconciles,
uh,
what seem like disparate
facts in the poem.
Well now I just want to point out that
close reading can always be pushed
farther. That's the difficulty
about close reading. You know,
it's all very well to say, look at
me, I'm reconciling harmony's, I'm,
I'm, you know, I'm creating patterns. I'm,
I'm showing the purpose of image
clusters and all the rest of it.
But if you keep doing it,
once you have yoked together,
becomes on yoked again, it falls apart.
Or at least it threatens to do so.
A contemporary of Brooks is named FW
Bateson wrote an essay on this same poems
she dwelt among on tried and ways in
which he points out this is the palms on
page eight oh two in which he points out
that the poem is full of
oxymorons contradictions in
terms untrodden ways away
as a path. But how can they be a
path if it's not trodden? What?
What is the meaning of an
untrodden way or in an or?
There are none to praise her,
but very few to love. Why?
Why call attention?
Not so much to the difference between
few lover and non praiser as the notion
that non praiser this is palpably false
because here's the poet praising her,
right? So what does he mean?
None? Why is he calling attention?
In other words to this,
this,
this logical disparity she lived
unknown and few could know.
How can she be unknown if you know
anything about her. In other words,
the palm is full of,
not of of complexities,
but who says they're being
reconciled. They're just
sitting there. Oxymoronic Lee,
you know, not reconciling
themselves at all. So Bates,
his argument is that Wordsworth
is calling attention to a,
to a conflict of emotion or
feeling that can't be reconciled.
Hence the path those of the ending.
Oh, the difference to me and so on.
And this, as I say, uh, is a
different use of close reading.
It's close reading,
which is not in the service
of unity or of unification,
but recognizes that the very arts whereby
we see a thing as a unified whole can
just as easily be put to the purpose
of blasting it apart again and,
uh, and, and of calling
our attention to that,
which can't be reconciled just as the
speaker can't be reconciled to the death
of Lucy.
Now the new critics can,
I think,
be criticized for that reason.
And the aftermath of the,
the historical close reading aftermath
of the new criticism does precisely that.
The,
if,
if one sees deconstruction as a response
to the new criticism and it's not just
that as we'll see,
it's a great many other things to that
response consists essentially in saying,
look, you can't just arbitrarily tie a
ribbon around something and say, Aha,
it's a unity, right? The ribbon comes off,
things fly apart as the poet. Uh, and uh,
it's not a unity after all.
Uh,
there is another aspect of the way
in which the new criticism has been
criticized for the last 40 or 50 years,
which needs to be touched on.
The notion of autonomy,
the notion of the freedom of the poem
from any kind of dependence in the world
is something that is very
easy to undermine. Critically.
Think of Brooks's analysis of Randall,
Gerald's eighth air force.
It concludes on the last page of the
essay by saying this is a bomb about human
nature,
about human nature under stress.
Whether or not human
nature is or is not good.
And arguments of this kind arguments of
the kind set forth by the poem can make
better citizens of us.
In other words,
the experience of reading poetry is
not just an aesthetic experience.
It's not just a question of private
reconciliation, of, of conflicting needs.
It's a social experience on this view.
And the social experience is
intrinsically a conservative one.
In other words,
it insists on the need
to balance opinions,
to balance viewpoints to balance needs
precisely in a way which is of course,
uh,
in implicitly a kind of
social and political centrism.
In other words,
how can poetry on this view,
how can literature be
progressive for that matter?
How can it be reactionary?
How, in other words,
can it be put to political purposes
if there's this underlying,
this implicit centrism in
this notion of reconciliation,
harmonization balance.
And that is has been a frequent source
of the criticism of the new criticism,
uh, in its aftermath over
the last 40 or 50 years.
There's also the question of religion.
There's a kind of implicit Episcopalian
perspective that you see in Brooks is
essay, what he's talking about, the
Shakespeare poem, uh, in which, um,
in which under the aspect of eternity,
inevitably things here on
earth seem ironic. And,
and there is always, there's, there's that
play of thought, uh, uh, throughout, uh,
the thinking of the new criticism as well.
Naturally,
one will think of things in ironic terms.
If one sees them from the perspective
of the divine or of the eternal moment.